willkommen an der Militärakademie Wiener
Neustadt ich bin Oberst Markus Reisner
der Leiter der Forschungs- und
Entwicklungsabteilung derzeit der
kommandanz der Garde in Wien in unserem
heutigen Video wollen wir ganz kurz die
letzten elf Monate betrachten das
Konflikts in der Ukraine des Angriffs
Russlands auf die Ukraine wir wollen uns
ansehen die ersten Erfahrungen die wir
bereits jetzt da ableiten können und
mögliche Herausforderungen die wir in
diesen Konflikt in den nächsten Monaten
noch sehen werden
beginnen wir ganz kurz zu Verordnung mit
dem Koordinatensystem in dem was ich
meine Aussagen getroffen werden dazu
muss man verstehen dass wir hier
tatsächlich in diesem Konflikt bereits
eine Dimension haben die über mehrere
Domäne hinweggeht wir haben also
Elemente Luft Maritim Land natürlich
auch nicht zu vergessen den Weltraum den
cyberraum und den Informationsraum also
alte Ableitungen immer treffen kann
befinden oder finden in diesem Raum
statt
wir unterscheiden zuerst zwischen der
taktischen der operativen und der
strategischen Ebene die taktische Ebene
bezeichnet Elemente wie zum Beispiel
Waffensysteme die verschiedene
Fähigkeiten haben wie zum Beispiel
dieses amerikanische Heimatsystem die
operative Ebene bezeichnet offensiven
wie sie die offensiven waren von
ukrainischen Seite bei Kiew bei hakiv
oder auch bei Person oder auch der
Angriff der Russland Beginn des Krieges
die strategische Ebene ist aber jene
Ebene die entscheidet ob sie einen
Konflikt über lange Zeit führen können
oder nicht hier in diesem Fall der
Angriff der russischen Seite auf die
kritische Infrastruktur der Ukraine
beginnen wir ganz kurz zuerst mit der
taktischen Ebene was man hier
feststellen kann ist dass die Idee der
russischen Seite aus den Erfahrungen von
2014 mit bataillonstaktischen Gruppen
einzumarschieren so nicht funktioniert
hat warum die pathologische Gruppe hat
offensichtlich vor allem was den Anteil
der Infanterie betrifft eine
Unterlegenheit die sich gerecht hat beim
Angriff auf die ukrainische Seite die
Ukraine einen Seite hingegen hat ganz
entscheidend verstanden dass durch den
Einsatz zum Beispiel von präziser
Artillerie aber vor allem auch durch den
Einsatz leichte Elemente es möglich ist
dieser Struktur der russischen
angreifenden Kräfte etwas
entgegenzusetzen das heißt das
entscheidende auf taktische Ebene ist es
dass die Taktiken Techniken und auch die
Maßnahmen die man im Gefecht getroffen
hat hier entscheidend sind für den
Erfolg so wie wir ihn dann gesehen haben
von ukrainischen Seite am Beginn des
Konflikts
das zweite ist die operative Ebene die
Ebene auf der verschiedenen offensiven
durchgeführt worden sind hier ist da
ganz klar festzustellen dass die
ukrainische Seite nach dem ab Erfolg bei
Kiew diese Erfolge auch weiter
fortsetzen konnte und zwar bei den
offensiven bei hakif aber auch in
weiterer Folge beim Rückzug der
russischen Truppen aus Person auf die
andere Flussseite trotzdem muss man auch
feststellen dass auch die russische
Seite im Verlauf der letzten 11 Monate
Erfolge verzeichnen konnte das war der
Einnahme der Stadt Maria Polen nach
schweren und heftigen Gefechten und sehr
viel zivilen Opfern aber auch die
Kesselschlacht bei sie werden im Sommer
oder jetzt die Situation bei Solidar
Park Mut wo die ukrainische Seite sehr
sehr unter Druck steht und man erkennen
kann dass möglicherweise die russische
Art der Einsatzführung nämlich dieser
massiv ateliersatz ihnen zu Erfolg
verhilft wir nehmen aus dieser
Darstellung mit dass beide Seiten durch
eine hohe Flexibilität immer wieder in
der Lage waren sich auf die
verschiedenen Situationen einzustellen
und erfolgreich zu sein
die nächste Ebene ist die strategische
Ebene jene Ebene die entscheidend ist
wenn es darum geht eine Konflikt über
lange Zeit zu führen hier war es der
Fall dass die russische Seite erkannt
hat dass durch den Einsatz der
Luftstreitkräfte mit weitreichenden
Waffensystemen wie ballistischen Raketen
Gruß missiles aber auch Drohnen es
möglich ist die Achillesferse der
Ukraine anzugreifen und das ist die
kritische Infrastruktur das heißt obwohl
paradoxerweise die ukrainische Seite
sehr erfolgreich auf operative Ebene ist
hat sie die Herausforderung dass die
russische Seite auf strategische Ebene
immer wieder versucht die kritische
Infrastruktur und das ist natürlich die
Stromversorgung der Ukraine anzugreifen
und das ist sehr erfolgreich wir haben
es auch gesehen am Beginn des Krieges
dass die russische Luft dafür sehr wohl
in der Lage war ihre Ziele umzusetzen
das Ergebnis dieser Angriffe
strategischer Ebene ist dass wenn man an
diesen Bildern eines betrachtet die
Stromversorgung der Ukraine immer mehr
getroffen wird und die Ukraine die große
Herausforderung hat mit dem Einsatz der
eigenen Flieger Abwehr auf diese
strategischen Ebene dem etwas
entgegenzusetzen
hier geht es also vor allem um die
Ausdauer diesen von Konflikt
weiterführen zu können
springe mir nun auf die Fähigkeiten die
Fähigkeiten die entscheidend sind das
Streitkräfte in einem Konflikt quasi
Erfolge oder Misserfolge erzielen diese
entsprechenden Fähigkeiten sind hier
abgebildet nur gemeinsam und
ineinandergreifend ist es möglich durch
Einsatz dieser Fähigkeiten tatsächlich
Erfolge zu erzielen beginnen wir mit der
ersten Fähigkeit der Vorbereitung hier
hat man gesehen dass der Eimer der
russischen Seite auf Annahmen passiert
die sich dann in weiterer Folge nicht
dass umsetzbar herausgestellt haben ein
gutes Beispiel ist die Schlacht um Kiew
wo in den ersten 48 Stunden das Gefechts
zugunsten der Ukraine entschieden worden
ist die Ukraine hat damals den Fluss
ihren aufgestaut die Brücken gesprengt
und durch den Einsatz von Artillerie die
Angreifer in russischen Elemente
nachhaltig geschlagen
auf der anderen Seite hervorragende
dargestellt für die ukrainische Seite
hat sich vor allem der Einsatz von
kleineren Einheiten unter Spezialkräfte
denn diese haben vor allem in
nadelstichtaktik versucht den Russen
Schaden zuzufügen und das auch sehr
erfolgreich umgesetzt das heißt hier
ganz klar der Vorteil einen
entsprechenden vorausschauenden Planung
der hier entscheidend für die
ukrainische Seite war die Vorbereitung
auf diesen Krieg
sehen wir uns nun den zweiten Begriff an
project also die Fähigkeit Kräfte zu
projizieren hier sind interessant
festzustellen dass in diesen elf Monaten
trotzdem missglückten Angriff der
russischen Seite ist den Russen immer
wieder gelungen ist sich neu auf
Situationen einzustellen wir haben das
also hier gerade auch am Beispiel von
Kiew noch einmal ob wir sie sehen können
dass die Russen innerhalb von wenigen
Tagen knapp von zwei Wochen fast 50 bis
60 000 Soldaten aus dem Raum Kiew
abgezogen haben im Eisenbahntransport
1000 km in den Don Bass verlegt haben
und dort dann versucht er mit einer
neuen Phase noch mal anzusetzen auf der
anderen Seite hat es die Ukraine
geschafft die Waffenlieferungen die das
ganze Europa und auch aus den USA
eingetroffen sind vor allem im Polen in
das Land zu bringen und hier schnell und
rasch quasi zu den Kämpfen Verbänden
vorzubringen wo Sie in der Lage waren
diesen Abwehrkampf gegen die Russen
weiter zu führen bzw auch sie
vorzubereiten auf eine weitere Offensive
das heißt entscheidend war hier das
Momentum aufrecht zu halten um das
näheren
der Kräfte weiter sicherstellen zu
können
sehen wir uns nun die Fähigkeit
angefahren hier ist ganz entscheidend
dass wir erkennen können dass in diesen
elf Monaten vor allem die
Geschwindigkeit das entscheidende
Element war die Geschwindigkeit vor
allem beim Einsatz von Waffensystemen
wir haben erkannt dass die ukrainische
Seite was den Einsatz ihrer Artillerie
betroffen hat sehr schnell reagieren
konnte und Ziele bekämpfen konnte
während die russische Seite immer noch
sehr zentralistisch war Anforderungen
durchführen konnte auf druckinischen
Seite war es möglich Feuer Anforderungen
innerhalb von wenigen Minuten
tatsächlich umzusetzen während auf der
russischen Seite Ziele die man erkannt
hatte bei dem Eintreffen des
feuerkommandos also bei dem Eintreffen
der Granaten oft nicht mehr vorhanden
waren und man kann gut erkennen dass sie
gerade auch in diesem Konflikt diese
Fähigkeiten entscheidend ist aufgrund
des Einsatzes von massiven Artillerie
Waffen die also von beiden Seiten hier
eingesetzt werden sehen wir uns das
nächste Begriff
Schutz an also die Möglichkeit die
eigenen Kräfte zu schützen am Ende der
zweiten Phase wo also die russische
Seite vor
was die Jugend
bekämpft hat weil so dass durch die
Lieferung von speziellen Waffensystemen
und das war das heimat-system aus den
USA 20 Stück die hier geliefert worden
sind es möglich war die vor allem
Munitionsdepots der russischen Seite
anzugreifen innerhalb von wenigen Wochen
wurden hier massive Zerstörungen
durchgeführt und es hat eine Zeit
gedauert bis die russische Seite in der
Lage war sich hier wieder anzupassen
einerseits durch ein
verlegen dieser massiven Munitionslager
in viele einzelne teillager aber
andererseits auch durch den Schutz von
fliegerbesystemen wie zum Beispiel
diesen System
punchy hat es wiederum möglich gemacht
diese heimatraketen der ukrainischen
Seite zu bekämpfen dem musste etwas
entgegengesetzt werden und das war der
Einsatz von diesen Anti radarraketen aus
den USA die wiederum diese pansche
Systeme bekämpft haben damit das
Heimatsystem wieder in der Lage war
diese Waffenlager zu bekämpfen das heißt
man sieht das was sie immer wieder der
versucht aber aus einer symmetrischen
Situation in eine asymmetrische
überzugehen wichtig ist aber zu
verstehen dass der Schutz der Ressourcen
notwendig ist und diesen Krieg weiter
voranzutreiben und zu führen zu können
sehen wir uns nun die
Durchhaltefähigkeit an und zwar am
Beispiel der Kräfte vor allem auch jetzt
den Beispiel noch mit der
munitionseinsatz
wir wissen dass die russische Armee eine
gewisse Anzahl von Kräften verfügbar
hatte es gibt unterschiedliche Zahlen
dazu als Beispiel nehmen wir diese
10.000 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge
kampfschützenpanzer und circa 1500
Panzer die sich in den Einsatz gebracht
haben tatsächlich sind diese Zahlen noch
wesentlich höher man geht davon aus dass
Russland um die 10.000 Panzer
tatsächlich verfügbar hat mit der
Instandsetzung wäre sicher möglich ca
drei bis dreieinhalb tausend für einen
Einsatz im Gefecht sind verfügbar zu
machen auf der anderen Seite die
ukrainische Seite hat dann Beginn des
Krieges ebenfalls signifikante Mengen
verfügbar gehabt man nimmt an dass die
Jugendlichen Streitkräfte die
quantitativ stärksten Streitkräfte
Europas übrigens waren über 2000
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge Kampf
Schützenpanzer über 1000 Panzer die hier
verfügbar waren diese Kräfte wurden
verwendet um in der ersten Phase die
angreifenden russischen Kräfte
abzunutzen das heißt russland hat sehr
hohe Verluste erlitten aber auch die
Ukraine hat sehr hohe Verluste erlitten
bis im Juni also ukrainischen Hälfte ihr
Equipments der Langstrecke die
Problematik besteht aber auch gerade in
der Munition und im munitionseinsatz am
Beispiel hat die Munition gezeigt man
nimmt andersrussland ca 17 Millionen
Schuss Artillerie Munition verfügbar
hatte von denen in den letzten elf
Monaten sieben Millionen verbraucht
worden sind die eigenen
Produktionskapazitäten sind ca 3,4
Millionen das heißt man hat also noch 10
Millionen plus die Produktion dieses
Jahres und ist in der Lage diesen Krieg
auch länger zu führen auf der anderen
Seite hat die Ukraine ihre Munition
relativ rasch verbraucht und hier ist
das Ziel des umstellens auf die
westlichen Kaliber wie das Kaliber 155
mm und auch die Ukraine weiter noch
versorgen zu können und das was ein
Gerät bereits geliefert worden ist das
hat die Ukraine in die Lage versetzt
dann im Sommer die offensiven bei
Personen und haargift durchzuführen wenn
man jetzt aber genau hinhört dann hört
man dass der ukrainische generalstoffe
ganz klar gesagt hat wenn ihr wollt dass
wir wieder in die Offensive gehen dann
brauche ich noch einmal eine dritte
Lieferung ich brauche noch einmal 3
Panzer ich brauche noch mal sechs bis
700 km Schützenpanzer ich brauche noch
einmal 500 Artillerie Systeme das heißt
die ukrainischen Langstrecke müssen zum
dritten Mal neu offensiv gemacht werden
sehen wir uns nun den Begriff in Form an
in Form bedeutet vor allem Aufklärung
Aufklärung ist ganz entscheidend und
zwar bereits von Beginn des Krieges bis
jetzt das erste entscheidende zu
verstehen ist das mit Einsatz der
russischen Kräfte auf dem ukrainischen
Territorium also mit Angriff der
Russischen Föderation auf die Ukraine es
zu massiv Unterstützungsmaßnahmen
gekommen ist das Westens diese Maßnahmen
haben vor allem auch den
aufklärungsbereich betroffen durch
satellitenaufklärung durch Signal
intelligence und andere Möglichkeiten
wie auch zum Beispiel jungen
intelligence war es möglich ein sehr
genaues und es sagtes Lagebild über die
russische Einsatzführung zu bekommen
dieses Lagebild besteht bis heute es war
auch der Grund warum es gelungen ist für
die Ukraine doch einige generelle auf
russischer Seite zu töten und man hat
auch erkannten erkennen können das vor
allem der massive Einsatz von Drohnen
vor allem auf unterste Ebene man nimmt
an das zu jeden Tag das Konflikt
zwischen 4 und 5000 Drohnen
unterschiedlicher Größen im Einsatz sind
es möglich ist das eigene Lagebild
entscheiden zu verstärken
ein Teil dieser Drohnen wird unter
anderem auch eingesetzt zur eigenen
Aufklärung um ein Bild davon zu bekommen
ob man in der Lage ist seine Kräfte
getarnt und geschützt abzustellen oder
ob der Gegner mit seinen Drohnen in der
Lage ist diese aufzugeben das heißt
Drohnen spielen in diesem Konflikt eine
sehr sehr große Rolle nicht nur auf
unterste Ebene zur Aufklärung sondern
bis auch auf die obere Ebene inklusive
der Bewaffnung die wir auch hier im
Einsatz sehen
sehen wir uns nun als weiteres Beispiel
consult commande Controller an also die
Führungsfähigkeit hier gibt es zwei
Elemente die entscheidend sind zu
verstehen das eine ist die Art und Weise
der Führung das heißt die Fähigkeit vor
allem von unterster Ebene bis nach oben
vor allem im Sinne der Auftragstaktik zu
führen Auftragstaktik heißt dass der
Untergebene versteht was von ihm
gefordert wird und danach handelt und er
braucht die Kommunikation dazu hier muss
man ganz klar feststellen dass vor allem
durch den Einsatz des darlehensystems
die Ukraine bis heute in der Lage ist in
einer Art und Weise zu kommunizieren die
es für die russische Seite sehr schwer
macht diese zerstören und dass der
Einsatz dieser kleinen Einheiten die im
Sinne des Auftrages denken dazu geführt
hat dass viele der offensiven sehr
erfolgreich durchgeführt werden konnten
auf der anderen Seite haben wir auf der
russischen Seite eine sehr
zentralistische Führung die Zeit braucht
um Entscheidungen von oben bis nach
unten zu kommunizieren wenn diese
Entscheidungen getroffen sind ist es
aber auch für die russische Seite
möglicher Folge zu ziehen man hat es
sehr gut gesehen auch bei Person hier
wurde
die schmerzhafte Entscheidung
vorgeschlagen offensichtlich am Putin
und auch genehmigt der Rücknahme der
Kräfte auf die andere Seite hier ist
bemerkenswert dass diese 30.000 Mann und
ca zweieinhalb tausend Fahrzeuge ohne
dass von dunklenische Seite den Schuss
abgegeben worden ist sich auf die andere
Seite zurückziehen konnten was ein
bisschen im Vergleich historisch mit den
Kirchen bemüht denn damals 1940 war es
auch möglich für die britische Seite
Kräfte auf Großbritannien überzusetzen
die dann in weiterer Folge des Krieges
verfügbar waren und auch hier sehen wir
jetzt dass diese 30.000 Mann nach dem
Abzug quasi verfügbar waren einerseits
am Südufer aber auch in weiterer Folge
bei minitopol oder auch natürlich bei
den Kämpfen im dompass die sich wieder
zugespitzt haben
sie werden sich nun die Frage stellen
woher diese Bewertungen stammen die wir
in den roten Textfeldern dargestellt
haben interessant ist dass in den
letzten elf Monaten bereits einiges an
Berichten erschienen ist die sich
kritisch mit der den Erfahrungen dieses
Konflikts auseinandersetzen Erfahrungen
die wichtig sind für die Zukunft von
Streitkräften ich möchte jetzt zwei als
Beispiel nennen beide Ausarbeitungen des
Rohr United Service Institute Fans in
Security Status der eine Ausarbeitung
befasst sich mit jenen Beobachtungen die
quasi gemacht worden sind in den ersten
Monaten des Krieges betreffendes der
russischen Streitkräfte in der Ukraine
was ist für die russische Seite gut
gelaufen was ist die russische schlecht
gelaufen es gibt eine zweite
Ausarbeitung die sich befasst mit den
ersten Erfahrungen und Bewertungen den
Einsatz der russischen Luftwaffe
betreffend wo war die russische
Luftwaffe erfolgreich und wo hat sie bis
heute es nicht geschafft dadurch
schlagen Erfolge zu ziehen ich habe aber
auch zitiert den ukrainischen Chef der
amerikanischen generalstoffchef und als
Beispiel den Leiter des Esstischen
Nachrichtendienstes
hat vor kurzem gesagt wenn die Ukraine
Armee wieder in die Offensive gehen soll
bevor die Seite sich eingegraben hat
dann brauche ich neuerlich 300 Panzer 6
bis 700 Gramm Schützenpanzer und 500
artilleriesysteme das heißt die
Kaninchen Langstrecke müssen zum dritten
Mal mit Kräften ausgestattet werden um
wieder offensiv zu werden der
us-generalstoffchef hat nach dem Abzug
der russischen Streitkräfte von Personen
gesagt dass beide Seiten 100.000 Mann an
Toten und Verwundeten erlitten war haben
er war der erste der das so in dieser
Form gesagt hat er hat aber auch gesagt
dass der Sieg der Ukraine bei Personen
die Möglichkeit für Verhandlungen öffnen
sollte dem wurde widersprochen
und an letzter Stelle möchte ich nennen
den Leiter des Esstischen
militärnachrichtendienstes der sehr klar
herunterdekliniert hat dass die
Möglichkeit der Ressourcen Nutzung von
russischer Seite noch sehr hoch ist
einerseits was die munitionsausstattung
betrifft aber auch die Verfügbarkeit von
gepanzerten Fahrzeugen und ich möchte
aus diesen zwei von mir genannten
Dokumenten ein Zitat herausnehmen dass
im Prinzip im Kern eine wesentliche
Aussage trifft denn es ist wichtig zu
verstehen dass wenn wir verstehen wollen
wie der Konflikt sich tatsächlich
entwickelt wo wir stehen und wo auch für
uns Ableitungen zu treffen sind es
nichts bringt die russische Seite als
inkompetent und nicht einsatzfähig zu
bezeichnen sondern dass wir anerkennen
müssen dass es Erfolge gegeben hat die
wichtig sind zum Verstehen um uns auf
eine mögliche weitere Eskalation des
Konfliktes vorzubereiten
ich gebe Ihnen auch ein Beispiel der
britische Nachrichtendienst versorgt uns
immer wieder mit nachrichtendienstliche
Informationen und die haben wir zwei
Beispiele gegenüber gelegt einmal vom
Juni des Jahres letzten Jahres und
einmal vom Dezember hier können wir
lesen dass der Einsatz der russischen
Luftwaffe und der Einsatz der
präzisionsmarktflugkörper offensichtlich
keinen Effekt erzielt hier im Dezember
sieht die Situation ganz anders aus hier
kann man bereits erkennen dass der
Einsatz dieser Marschflugkörper
ballistischen Raketen und Drohnen sehr
wohl einen Effekt erzielt nämlich auf
dieser strategischen Ebene wo Russland
immer noch festlegen kann wann wo und in
welchem Umfang ist die Jugendliche Seite
trifft die immer noch das Problem hat
der mangelhaft vorhandenen Flieger
Abwehr und das Problem ist immer
zunehmen Zerstörung da geht es
Infrastruktur wir sehen das auch in
einem Zitat des Präsidenten der im
November gesagt hat dass bis jetzt über
4.700 polizistische Raketen machen
gegeneinander eingesetzt worden sind
mittlerweile ist die Zahl 5000 plus das
ist eine Zahl die ist noch nie so in der
Kriegsgeschichte gab und viele dieser
Raketen treffen ihre Ziele das haben wir
spätestens seit dem 10 Oktober gesehen
wo es zu diesem Schädigungen
energetischen Infrastruktur kommt und wo
klar ist dass die ukrainische Seite
Flugabwehrsysteme braucht um dem etwas
entgegenzusetzen aber nicht ein oder
zwei Beton Batterien sondern viele viele
mehr
während im Westen
Rätselraten über die Einsatzfähigkeit
der russischen Streitkräfte herrscht
versucht die russische Seite ganz
gezielt durch eine Vielzahl von Formaten
entsprechend diese narrative so zu
füttern dass klar ist dass das was die
russische Armee sich vorgenommen hat sie
auch tatsächlich umsetzen können und
hier gibt es eine ganze Reihe von
offensiv aber auch im Hintergrund
agierenden
nachrichtenformaten vor allem in den
sozialen Netzwerken die hier ganz
versuchen gezielt die Informationen
weiterzugeben dass es auf der Eindruck
entsteht das ist ja hier sehr große
Erfolge erzielt werden und das ist
natürlich genau die Propaganda der die
russische Seite die russische
Bevölkerung unterworfen ist
wenn wir uns jetzt am Ende fragen was
fehlt noch ein Ausstattung und Gerät bzw
wie kann der Konflikt weiter verlaufen
so ist ganz interessant dass mehrere
Fragen die ich kurz stelle Ihnen einen
Aufschluss darüber geben können wir
haben bereits gesehen den Einsatz des
amerikanischen heimatsystems hier war es
so dass der Amerikaner 20 Stück
geliefert haben und 18 Stück für die
nächsten zwei Jahre zugesagt haben die
nächsten wurden bereits in kürzen
Aussicht gestellt die ukrainische Seite
hat aber 50 bis 100 gefordert das ist
das militärische Sicht auch legitim denn
nur das kann eine tatsächliche Effekte
ziehen die zweite Frage die wir
verstehen müssen warum wurden bis jetzt
keine Kampfflugzeuge geliefert keine
Kampfflugzeuge vom 16 oder
erdkampfflugzeuge vom Typ A10 auch das
würde zu einem möglichen Eskalation
offensichtlich führen das gleiche gilt
für die Lieferung von weitreichenden
Waffensystemen wir haben zwar einige
Einsätze gegeben gesehen von
weitreichenden Waffen z.B auf der Krim
bei Saki aber auch z.B auf Englisch oder
in der Tiefe
Russlands oder zum Beispiel auf sie
Wasser holen aber es gab immer noch
keine Lieferung dieser attackers
bei den fliegerabwehrsystemen hat sich
jetzt langsam begonnen die Lieferungen
dahingehend zu entwickeln dass alles
dieses Thema aber auch petschutzsysteme
geliefert worden sind aber auch hier ist
die Menge nach wie vor gering um
nachhaltig einen abwehrfolg zu ziehen
und das letzte Thema das sehr intensiv
diskutiert wird ist natürlich die
Lieferung von Panzern und hier ist es so
dass momentan zugesagt sind 50 Stück
kampfschützenpanzer Bradley 40 Stück
Marder
Großbritannien hat ein Aussicht gestellt
zehn Kampfpanzer vom Typ Challenger und
Finnland und Polen haben ebenfalls in
Aussicht gestellte Lieferung von Leopard
Panzern wenn man diese Zahlen
zusammenrechnet und vergleicht mit den
Forderungen von General solution dann
sieht man ganz klar die Ablage gerade
320 in Aussicht gestellt ist jetzt die
Lieferung von 30 erfordert 6 bis 700
Kampf Schützenpanzer zusammengezählt ist
dass die Zahl von ca 90 und die
Artillerie Systeme die ebenfalls zu
liefern sind sind in dieser Lieferung
noch gar nicht eingeschlossen aber wenn
die Ukraine quasi weiter in die
Offensive gehen will dann braucht sie
natürlich diese Ausstattung um hier
gegen die russische Seite vor
angreifen zu können vor allem wenn man
bedenkt dass die russische Seite sich
jetzt in den letzten Wochen Monaten in
dem von ihnen im Besitz genommenen
Gelände eingegraben hat durch Panzer
Igel durch spermaßnahmen durch
Minenfelder und so weiter und so fort
und das zusätzliche Kräfte herangeführt
werden
wenn wir uns jetzt noch mal kurz diese
drei Ebenen vor Augen führen didaktische
die operative und die strategische so
sind folgende Entwicklungen interessant
die taktische Ebene hat immer noch die
Herausforderung dass beide Seiten in
einem Kräfteverhältnis stehen auf der
einen Seite die russische Seite die mit
zu geringen Kräften begonnen hat die
aber durch das Nachführen von
Reservisten langsam beginnt die
ukrainische Seite in der Verfügbarkeit
von Kräften zu Überholen auf der anderen
Seite die Verfügbarkeit von Fahrzeugen
wie Panzern kampfschützenpanzern und
natürlich Systemen wo wir immer noch
erkennen können dass es ein Delta gibt
zwischen dem was die Ukraine verfügbar
hat und immer verfügbar hat und Russland
beginnt immer mehr Ressourcen verfügbar
zu machen und neue Kräfte heranzuführen
wir haben noch immer in der Woche ca ein
zwei Militär Züge die herangebracht
werden während die Waffenlieferungen aus
dem Westen aus Europas der USA relativ
spärlich von Staaten gehen entscheidende
Durchbrüche die Lieferung von hunderten
Systemen gleichzeitig haben wir bis
jetzt noch nicht gesehen
wenn wir uns die operative Ebene ansehen
dann ist die Frage was soll mit diesem
Waffen passieren und hier ist es die
Absicht der ukrainischen Seite zwei coas
aufzustellen also Formationen mit
mehreren 10.000 Mann einmal im Raum
Polter war und einmal bei Nepo im
Schneebrücke diese beiden course würden
sich für folgende einsatzführungen aus
operativer Sicht eignen einmal nach
einer Bereitstellung der Angriff in
Richtung dompass mit dem Ziel die
Versorgungslinien in den dompass
abzuschneiden oder andererseits außer
heraus antretend in Richtung Süden die
landlinie die Landverbindung zu
unterbrechen mit einem angeführten in
Kombination mit einem neuerlichen
Versuch der Zerstörung oder Bestätigung
der Brücke über die Straße von Gerhardt
dieser Ansatz wäre der
erfolgversprechende denn es würde somit
gelingen die russischen Kräfte auf der
Creme in Personen das ist ja
abzuschneiden und die russische Seite
hätte ganz andere Herausforderungen zu
bestehen als zurzeit das nährende
Angriffe quasi im Park muss oder was
auch im Wasser
das strategische Element ist ebenfalls
nicht zu unterschätzen und hier kennen
wir das aufgrund der Angriffe der
kritischen Infrastruktur es zweierlei
Art der Maßnahmen gibt auf der einen
Seite versucht die Ukraine durch
Defensive Maßnahmen durch Fliegerabwehr
diesen Angriffen entsprechend etwas
entgegenzusetzen und wir erkennen auch
dass die Abschlusszahlen der
einfliegenden iranischen Drohnen aber
auch der Einblick in maschenkörper immer
mehr zunehmen auf der anderen Seite
versucht man aber auch offensiv jene
Räume zu treffen von denen aus diese
Angriffe geflogen werden also der
Einsatzraum der russischen strategischen
Bomber tief in Russland selbst oder zum
Beispiel die Basen der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte den Sebastopol diese
Schiffe von denen aus diesem Arschloch
Körper gestartet werden die dann quasi
Ziele in der Ukraine treffen
abschließend muss man feststellen dass
das was ich in den ersten Monaten des
Konflikts herauskristallisiert hat
nämlich der Umstand dass dieser kriege
es abnutzungskrieg geführt wird sich
immer mehr tatsächlich der Wahrheit
entsprechend darstellt wir sehen das
hier an diesem Bild dieses Bild zeigt
eine von granatstrichtern sofort die
Fläche bei Park Mut übersät von
getöteten russischen Angehörigen das
sollten der Gruppe Wagner wir haben
erkennt hier eine Art der Kriegsführung
die wir in dieser Form nicht mehr für
möglich gehalten haben eine Art der
Kriegsführung die an die Schlachtfelder
des Ersten Weltkrieges von der drei oder
auch an den Saison zu erinnert und diese
Art der Kriegsführung ist natürlich für
keine Konfliktparteien verheiratet wir
sehen das hier an diesem Zitat auf der
einen Seite hat die russische Seite
immer noch die Herausforderung dass sie
dazu wenig Infanterie verfügt um eine
Entscheidung herbeizuführen auf der
anderen Seite ist die ukrainische es
sind die ukrainische Streitkräfte
gefordert die von ihnen im Besitz haben
im Geländeteile so lange wie möglich zu
verteidigen und zu verhindern dass die
russische Seite diese einnimmt was dazu
führt dass es zum Teil schwerste
Verluste gibt so wie sie gesehen haben
weil diese Chance sie wäre
da oder auch gut
die Frage ist nun am Ende wer wird den
längeren Atem haben in der nächsten
Woche und Monaten und wir sehen dass die
Unterstützung der Ukraine aus
militärischer Sicht vor allem von den
USA stattfindet während der europäischen
Arsenale zunehmend unter Druck kommen
auf der anderen Seite sehen wir dass die
russische Rüstungsindustrie bereits in
drei Schichtbetrieb arbeitet und auch
zunehmend moderneres Systeme an der
Front eingesetzt werden trotz der hohen
Verlustraten die einen aus westlicher
Sicht unglaublich erscheinen ist es der
russischen Seite immer noch möglich die
angriffsfähigkeit dahingehend zu nähern
das in der Lage sind die von ihnen im
Besitz genommenen Gelände Teile zu
halten
damit bin ich am Ende meiner
Präsentation die Botschaft die ich Ihnen
mitgeben kann ist dass dieser Konflikt
noch länger dauern wird und wir dürfen
nicht nur auf die Ukraine und auf
Russland sehen sondern wir müssen auch
bedenken dass kräftig im Hintergrund
eine Rolle spielen also China der Iran
oder vielleicht auch sogar Indien oder
auf der anderen Seite natürlich die USA
die Europäische Union oder andere
signifikante Unterstützer man kann sich
den Konflikt auch vorstellen wie eine
Boxkampf eine Runde nach der anderen
findet statt die ukrainische Seite hat
mehrere Runden nach Punkten gewonnen
aber es hat bis jetzt noch kein k.o
gegeben damit bin ich am Ende meiner
Ausführungen ich sage herzlichen Dank
fürs zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal